It also became
clear that there was
one other way to increase the
capacity of a communication
system.
We can increase the number of
different signalling events.
For example, with Alice and
Bob's string communication
system, they soon found that
varying the type of plucks
allowed them to send
their messages faster.
For example, hard, medium,
versus soft plucks,
or high pitch versus
low pitch plucks
by tightening the cable
different amounts.
And this was an idea implemented
by Thomas Edison, which
he applied to the
Morse code system.
And it was based on
the idea that you
could use weak and
strong batteries
to produce signals of
different strengths.
He also used two directions,
as Gauss and Weber did, forward
versus reverse current,
and two intensities.
So he had plus 3 volts,
plus 1 volt, minus 1 volt,
and minus 3 volt-- four
different current values
which could be exchanged.
It enabled Western
Union to save money
by greatly increasing the number
of messages the company could
send without building new lines.
And this is known as the
quadruplex telegraph,
and it continued to be
used into the 20th century.
But again, as we
expanded the number
of different signaling events,
we ran into another problem.
For example, why not send
a thousand or a million
different voltage
levels per pulse?
Well, as you may expect,
fine-grain differences
lead to difficulties
on the receiving end.
And with electrical systems, the
resolution of these differences
is always limited
by electrical noise.
If we attach a probe
to any electrical line
and zoom in closely
enough, we will always
find minute, undesired currents.
And this is an unavoidable
result of natural processes,
such as heat, or
geomagnetic storms,
and even latent effects
of the big bang.
So the differences between
signaling events must be great
enough that noise cannot
randomly bump a signaling event
from one type to another.
Clearly, now, we can
step back and begin
to define the capacity of a
communication system using
these two very simple ideas.
First, how many symbol
transfers per second,
which we called symbol rate?
And today, it's known simply
as baud, for Emile Baudot.
And we can define
this as n, where
it's n symbol
transfers per second.
And number two, how many
differences per symbol, which
we can think of as
the symbol space?
How many symbols can we
select from at each point?
And we can call this s.
And as we've seen
before, these parameters
can be thought of as a
decision tree of possibilities,
because each symbol can be
thought of as a decision where
the number of branches depend
on the number of differences.
And after n symbols,
we have a tree with s
to the power of n leaves.
And since each path through this
tree can represent a message,
we can think of the
number of leaves
as the size of
the message space.
And this is easy to visualize.
The message space is simply
the width of the base of one
of these trees.
And it defines the total
number of possible messages
one could send given a
sequence of n symbols.
For example, let's
say Alice sends Bob
a message which
consists of two plucks,
and they're using a
hard versus soft pluck
as their communication system.
This means she has
the ability to define
one of four possible
messages to Bob.
And if instead they were using
a system of hard versus medium
versus soft plucks,
then with two plucks,
she has the ability to define
one of 3 to the power of 2
equals 9 messages.
And with three plucks, this
jumps to one of 27 messages.
Now if instead, Alice and Bob
were exchanging written notes
in class, which contain only
two letters on a piece of paper,
then a single note would contain
1 of 26 to the power of 2,
or 676 possible messages.
It's important to realize
now that we no longer care
about the meaning applied to
these chains of differences--
merely how many different
messages are possible.
The resulting sequences could
represent numbers, names,
feelings, music, or perhaps
even some alien alphabet
we could never understand.
When we look at a
communication system now,
we can begin to think
about its capacity
as how many different
things you could say.
And we can then use
the message space
to define exactly
how many differences
are possible in any situation.
And this simple yet elegant
idea forms the basis
for how information
will be later defined.
And this is the final step that
brings us to modern information
theory, and it emerges in
the early 20th century.